Jeanine Pirro is the host of Justice
with judge Jeanine she's the author of
the new book radicals resistance and
revenge
the left's plot to remake America it's
out today judge Jeanine joins us tonight
so it seems significant to me within the
context of all we've seen over the past
three years that the so-called
whistleblower the person who complained
about this conversation was a career CIA
officer well yeah because as you recall
Chuck Schumer is the one who said a long
time ago you don't mess with the
intelligence agencies because they'll
get back at you six ways to Sunday but
you know I must tell you tucker I mean
everything you said is so on point but
the most disappointing part of this is
when you've got someone joking about
impeaching a president making a parody
about you know an organized crime family
and then reading words that have nothing
to do with the actual transcript it's an
indication that they don't have a case
which is why they actually have to
parody and make up this now you listen
to me another seven times or you're not
going to get this out of the other thing
if there were an impeachable offense if
there were any evidence of any kind of
criminality any kind of illegalities he
would have read that statement per se
that would have been the end of it but
we're dealing with Adam Schiff and Adam
Schiff is the same guy who stumbled over
himself 86 times to get to a camera to
tell us that he knew more about Russia
collusion then Bob Muller did and
obviously he didn't and the sad part
about this is that this country has an
economy that is soaring we are now in a
position with the strongest military
ever but these haters who couldn't drag
Hillary Clinton across the presidential
finish line want to do everything they
can to impeach him if it's an
impeachable offense great if it's not no
problem we hate him we're going to get
him out and that's a sad point and by
the way let me make one more point this
president has an absolute right to get
to the bottom of what happened with
meddling in the 2016 election and nobody
in Congress and especially the Democrats
who were involved like James Comey
Brennan than the whole lot of them in
the Intel community
have the right to stop him and accuse
him of an impeachable offense because he
now has the right to get to the bottom
of it you think the next time a Democrat
is elected president and it will happen
the Democrats will be comfortable with
the standard they have set that if some
unelected Intel agency guy doesn't like
their foreign policy he can destroy
their administration are they going to
be they gonna be comfortable with that
do you think they're not even thinking
that far in advance Tucker because they
are so blinded by the hatred their
hatred of Donald Trump that they can't
even see what real criminality is and
that is when Joe Biden says you want to
talk about a godfather
you got six hours here you don't get a
billion dollars unless you take the
prosecutor off that company that my son
is on the board of that he's making
millions of dollars because he's about
ready to interrogate my son and I don't
want it to happen give me a break
this is a sad way but I don't think
you've been watching cable news judge I
mean I've learned this week that you
know hunter Biden was an expert in
Ukrainian energy policy and deserved
those hundreds of thousands ago I don't
want to get me started by Nazi do you
want to know why he's not in the middle
no no no no I don't want to hear
actually no hundred by two I think he's
a nice guy but it's fair to ask these
questions yeah yeah how do you think
three hours out of China that's a good
question no no somebody should even we
should get together and try it